la suite de l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion sur le rapport de la
commission mixte paritaire de la
proposition de loi visant à améliorer
l'accès aux soins par l'engagement
territorial des
professionnels merci et donc la parole
est à Monsieur Frédéric Valtou
rapporteur de la commission mixte
[Applaudissements]
paritaire
merci
beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales chers
collègues les mots du système de santé
sont multiples et dans son organisation
notre système de santé caractérisé
souvent par son
hypercentralisation parfois sa
suradministration et et certainement par
son extrême cloisonnement entre les
professionnels aux statuts différents
cette proposition de loi que j'ai eu
l'honneur de déposer au printemps
dernier avec mon groupe horizon mais
aussi avec le groupe Renaissance est un
texte pour faire passer une étape
nouvelle dans la territorialisation du
système de santé pour favoriser le
décloisonnement donner de l'oxygène et
de l'autonomie aux acteurs de terrain
c'est un texte de confiance aux
professionnels de santé oui le temps est
venu de faire confiance à tous ceux qui
directement les professionnels de santé
ou indirectement les administrations de
l'État la sécurité sociale les
collectivités locales les associations
de patients sont partie prenantes de la
question de l'organisation des soins oui
le temps est venu de mettre en œuvre des
réformes volontaristes en inscrivant
dans le droit positif certaines annonces
formulées par le Président de la
République notamment lors de ses vœux
aux soignants il y a un an tel que le
que le meilleur partage des efforts
entre tous les soignant je suis
convaincu que pour faire bouger les
lignes en matière de santé il nous faut
mobiliser toutes les bonnes volontés
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que ce sont
déroulés nos travaux autour de cette
proposition loi dans de multiples
échanges avant la discussion comme tout
au long de la navette avec de nombreux
collègues de tous les bancs de cette
hémicycle puis avec le Sénat et je m'en
félicite chacun a partagé cette ambition
de valoriser l'approche par les
territoire et chacun a pu apporter ainsi
de manière constructive sa pierre à ce
texte je pense d'abord au groupe
transpartisan sur les déserts médicaux
animés par notre collègue Guillaume
Garot dans notre volonté commune
d'encourager l'installation pérenne des
soignant incarné dans ce texte par
l'interdiction de l'intérim en début de
carrière les réflexions de ce groupe ont
apporté l'encadrement plus strict des
aides à l'installation pour lutter
contre le nomadisme médical ou
l'instauration d'un délai de prévenance
de 6 mois en cas de cessation d'activité
pour mieux organiser la continuité de
l'offre de soins dans les territoires au
titre des apports d'autres groupes
politiques je veux aussi citer celui de
de Yannick Neder concernant la prise en
compte dans le numérus apertus des
besoins de santé des territoires pour
fixer les objectifs pluriannuels
d'admission en 2e cycle forte de 11
articles lors de son dépôt la
proposition loi s'est enrichie au cours
de nos débats et de la navette
parlementairire pour en compter plus du
triple dans le texte qui vous est
proposé aujourd'hui par la
CMP le Sénat a enrichi le texte sans le
dénaturer parfois en renforçant la
portée de certaines dispositions je
pense à la permanence des soin
et lorsque leur tentation était de trop
céder à quelques intérêts catégoriels la
discussion en commission mixte paritaire
a permis de rééquilibrer les choses à
l'arrivée la copie aprement négociée
entre nos deux assemblées est équilibrée
et respecte l'ambition originelle de ce
texte tout en prenant en compte autant
que faire ce peu les sensibilités de
chacun sur les conseils territoriaux de
santé d'abord le texte conforte ces
instances de démocratie sanitaire en
leur confiant et cela n'est pas mince et
attendu et et c'est attendu par les élus
locaux en leur confiant la
responsabilité d'organiser la permanence
des soins ou d'améliorer l'accès aux
soins nous donnons ainsi de vrais
pouvoirs d'injonction à l'état en cas de
carence de la réponse des professionnels
en ville de la même manière le texte
contient des avancées notables pour les
patients d'abord il neutralise la
majoration du ticket modérateur pour
ceux d'entre eux qui n'ont plus de
médecin traitant pour les soignants
ensuite il étend le principe de
délégation de tâche en étendant
l'expérimentation la réalisation des
certificats de décès par les infirmiers
sur la permanence des soins nous savons
que nous étions très attendus partout en
France ce texte réduit la pression sur
l'hôpital qui porte aujourd'hui 83 % la
permanence des soins en établissement
demain tous les établissements de santé
et notamment les cliniques seront
parties prenantes au garde enfin à
l'hôpital nous apportons aussi des
progrès sur différents volets par
exemple en dotant le conseil de
surveillance de nouvelles prérogatives
et en renforçant la médicalisation de la
gouvernance hospitalière bien entendu je
suis conscient que cette proposition loi
n'est pas une potion miracle qui
guérirait d'un seul coup le système de
santé de tous ces mots demain il nous
faut mettre en œuvre des réformes
ambitieuse en poursuivant par exemple la
transformation profonde des études
médicales entamées en 2018 pour palier
l'importante pénurie de médecin où en
nous attaquant à toutes les dépenses
inutiles qui ne servent pas l'intérêt
général en santé pour autant avec les
avancées concrètes contenues dans ce
texte ce texte va faire œuvre utinle et
j'en suis profondément convaincu je le
dois à la confiance sans faille de mes
collègues députés du groupe horizon
ainsi qu'à celle des députés de la
majorité et notamment du groupe
Renaissance je dois aux contributions
très concrètte de plusieurs de nos
collègues notamment Stéphanie riste et
Jean-François Rousset ou d'anciens
collègues à qui je veux rendre hommage
comme Thomas Ménier ou Philippe Vigier
je le doit aussi à l'accompagnement des
collaborateurs du Groupe horizon et au
formidablebles travail des
administrateurs de notre de notre
assemblée que je veux remercier du fond
du cœur votons ce texte pour dire notre
confiance aux acteurs de terrain c'est
j'en suis convaincu je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau
ministre de la santé et de la
prévention
présidente madame la présidente madame
la ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés au cœur de la proposition de loi
dont l'ultime étape de l'examen
parlementaire nous réunit aujourd'hui il
y a une ambition celle d'accélérer le
décloisonnement de notre système de
santé avec des solutions concrètes pour
améliorer l'accès aux soins de nos
concitoyens et renforcer nos moyens de
lutte contre les inégalités de
santé aujourd'hui pour accompagner la
transformation de notre système de santé
je crois que nous nous retrouvons autour
de quelqu quelques principes d'abord le
principe de solidarité qui soutend notre
modèle de protection sociale la la
capacité aussi d'adaptation en fonction
des solutions trouvées sur les
territoires mais plus fondalement plus
fondamentalement encore et Frédéric
Valtou a évoqué à l'instant le
renforcement des coopérations et des
liens de confiance entre les différents
professionnels et tous les acteurs de la
santé j'insiste sur cette notion de
confiance quand c'est bien cela qui nous
a permis d'arriver aujourd'hui au stade
de la lecture des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire et je tiens
évidemment avant tout à remercier
l'auteur et rapporteur de ce texte
Frédéric Valtou je tiens aussi à saluer
le travail qui a été fait au Sénat par
la rapporteur Corine
Himbert les discussions ont été longues
et denses mais c'était extrêmement
précieux et elle s'exprimera après moi
tout le travail qui a été fait par Agnès
firman le baudau c'est un travail de
longue haline sous l'impulsion de
Frédéric Valtou qui nous a mené jusqu'à
cette CMP dont je me réjouis évidemment
qu'elle a été conclusive je veux
également prendre le temps de saluer le
travail constructif de fond qui a été
mené dans les deux assemblées pour
arriver à ce texte merci à tous les
députés qui se sont investis sur cette
PPL de tous les groupes parlementaire de
la majorité comme de l'opposition
ensemble nous avançons sur le chemin
d'un système de santé où chaque acteur
trouve sa place et a plus de moyens plus
de latitude pour agir en effet pour
transformer le fonctionnement et
l'organisation territoriale de notre
système de santé la réponse doit prendre
des formes doit prendre forme pardon
dans la cohérence et la complémentarité
des différentes politiques menées
aujourd'hui par ce texte qui permettra
de poser le cadre de collaboration d'une
collaboration rénovée et renforcée entre
les métiers mais aussi entre tous les
acteurs locaux professionnels élus et
citoyens et ainsi de mieux répondre aux
besoins de nos concitoyens et aux
tensions personne ne les n auxquel fait
face notre système de santé mais nous
mobilisons aussi d'autres levier
d'action ils sont nombreux en matière de
santé publique le gouvernement s'en
saisit pleinement le budget de la
Sécurité sociale pour
2024 comprend des mesures fortes pour
l'attractivité hospitalière et un
meilleur accès aux soins les
négociations conventionnelles sont en
cours avec les médecins libéraux et nous
devrions j'ai signé tout à l'heure la
lettre de cadrage les rouvrir très
prochainement sur l'avenant avec les
pharmaciens sans oublier les différentes
propositions de loi qui ont été
travaillé ces dernières années ici même
avec des avancées importantes je pense
bien sûr ici tout particulièrement aux
deux lois porté par la rapporteur
général de votre commission des affaires
sociales Stéphanie Rist je veux citer
aussi le travail qui a été fait au sein
du groupe transpartisan nous ne
partageons pas toutes les Ori
orientation mais je suis convaincu et je
le je le reconnais tout à fait qu'il a
aussi nourri le travail du gouvernement
je ne ni pas que les je ne ni pas que
les défis à relever sont encore immenses
que oui nous faisons face à des tensions
importantes notamment en ce qui concerne
nos ressources humaines mais la
proposition de loi que N que vous aurez
aujourd'hui à adopter comporte une
partie des solutions y compris à court
terme qui nous font avancer dans la
bonne dans la bonne direction toutes les
solutions évidemment non
une partie d'avancé concrète oui et je
crois c'est l'esprit dans lequel
Frédéric Valtou avait voulu construire
depuis le départ ce projet de texte je
pense notamment à l'élargissement de la
responsabilité collective d'organisation
de la permanence des soins en
établissement de santé qui revient aux
établissements et aux et aux
professionnels de santé qui les
composent dans le public comme dans le
privé c'est un dispositif essentiel qui
a été affiné durant le débat et qui
permettra notamment de rééquilibrer ce
que l'on entend beaucoup quand on
discute dans les différentes visites
dans les hôpitaux publics de
rééquilibrer la charge de cette
responsabilité de la permanence des
soins entre le secteur public et le
secteur privé pour réduire la pression
sur l'hôpital et assurer à chaque
citoyen que là où il en aura besoin
quand il en aura besoin il y aura
toujours une réponse du système de santé
pour nos établissements de santé nous
savons combien les attentes du secteur
hospitalier étaient fortes pour aboutir
à une mesure permettant à la fois de
doter les groupements HP alier de
territoire de la personnalité morale
mais aussi de faciliter les
regroupements entre ces groupements
hospitaliers de territoire et je salue
le dialogue intense mais fructueux qui a
permis de traduire cette volonté de
manière opérationnelle cette proposition
de loi permet également de poursuivre
l'effort de régulation et d'encadrement
de la pratique de l'intérim médical avec
son interdiction en début de carrière
qui présente le double avantage de
stabiliser les collectifs de travails
hospitaliers et de mieux accompagner
l'entrée dans la vie professionnelle des
jeunes soignants en sécurisant le
passage du statut d'étudiant à celui de
professionnel de santé disant cela je
mesure et je crois que chacun le sait ce
que cela peut avoir encore comme effet
déstabilisant dans certains
établissements mais je crois que
personne ne remet en cause la nécessité
de mettre en œuvre cette disposition
importante de la deuxème loi portée par
Stéphanie riste pour ce qui concerne
plutôt les fins de carrière ce texte
permet la concrétisation d'un engagement
important ancien presque une arlaisienne
qui est la prise en compte des des
émoluments hospitalier dans le calcul de
la retraite des personnels hospitalaux
universitaires c'est là une mesure de
justice sociale que nous avons porté
avec Sylvie retaillot qui correspond à
la juste reconnaissance sociale de
l'exercice médical des hospitalau
universitaires je veux vous assurer que
nous accompagneront cette réforme pour
qu' celle-ci puisse pleinement produire
ses effets et améliorer évidemment le
niveau de de remplacement des
professionnels hospitalau universitaires
lorsque ceuxci liquident leurs droits à
la retraite parmi les autres grandes
dispositions concrètes permises par le
texte on peut également citer la
suppression de la majoration du ticket
modérateur pour les patients n'ayant pas
de médecin traitant ou encore et là
aussi c'est quelque chose de tangible
d'efficace immédiatement le renforcement
du rôle du médecin coordonnateur anpad
et la création de la fonction
d'infirmier référent mesdames et
messieurs les députés le succès que
représente l'aboutissement d'un texte
comme celui-ci est la preuve de notre
capacité à trouver des solutions
utiles qui contribuent à renforcer la
confiance donnée aux acteurs de terrain
pour susciter leur engugement encourager
leur meilleure coordination et renforcer
leur responsabilité ce sont pour moi les
maîtres mots qui permettent ensuite
l'attractivité et la fidélisation
partout sur le territoire je l'ai dit
d'entrée d'entrée de jeu ce texte
s'inscrit dans un Chartier plus large de
notre action résolue au service de nos
concitoyens et des professionnels le
travail se poursuit je souhaite que nous
continuions à avancer ensemble dans
cette dynamique et cet état d'esprit
mais je pense qu'avec la proposition de
loi sur laquelle vous allez délibérer
aujourd'hui nous posons une brique
essentielle de ce chantier je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame agnè firm lebudau
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professionnels de
santé
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés au côté d'Aurélien
Rousseau je salue l'accord auquel
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
esttent parvenu sur ce texte je veux
remercier particulièrement le rapporteur
Frédéric Valtou ce texte traduit son
engagement celui du groupe horizon et de
la majorité pour porter des solutions
concrète en faveur de l'accès aux soins
dans les territoires et donner de
nouveaux outils et Levi d'action aux
acteurs il s'inscrit dans une continuité
celle d'une majorité à la tâche pour
porter des mesures en faveur de l'accès
aux soins je pense bien sûr au textes
porté par Stéphanie Rist ou votre
ancienne présidente de commission Fadila
catabi ces initiatives sont
complémentaires de l'action du
gouvernement en faveur de l'accès aux
soins merci donc à tous les acteurs ici
comme au Sénat et je tiens à saluer
particulièrement l'engagement de Corine
Amber au Sénat qui ont travaillé dans un
esprit constructif pour faire aboutir ce
texte en juillet dernier j'ai présenté
un plan d'action important en matière
d'accès aux soins autour de quatre
piliers le recrutement de 10000
assistants médicaux le développement de
4000 maisons de santé pouris
professionnel la généralisation des CPTs
sur l'ensemble du territoire et le
déploiement de 100 médicobus pour faire
ce fameux dernier kilomètre qui est si
difficile ce plan doit permettre d'ici à
la fin du quinquena à 2 millions de
Français supplémentaires d'avoir accès à
un médecin j'en ai réalisé un premier
bilan d'étape lors d'un déplacement
récent dans l'Orne la dynamique est
bonne sur l'ensemble de ces chantiers
sur lesquelles nous avançons main dans
la main avec l'ensemble des acteurs
nationaux et sur le terrain en parallèle
face au manque de soignant nous devons
continuer de mieux utiliser les
compétences de chacun en déployant le
partage des tâches et les élargissements
de compétences entre les professionnels
de santé en 2 ans ce sont presque 20
nouvelles délégations de tâches qui ont
été décidées souvent par le biais d'un
travail parlementaire elle nécessite
aujourd'hui d'être pleinement déployé
mais surtout d'être mieux connu des
patients pour faciliter leur accès aux
soins il nous faut absolument
collectivement améliorer la
communication autour de ces nouvelles
possibilités qui demeurent trop peu
connu de nos
concitoyens cette proposition de loi
s'inscrit pleinement dans cette
dynamique et la volonté du gouvernement
et de l'ensemble des parlementaires quel
que soit leur ban de porter des mesures
concrètes pour conforter notre ambition
en santé sur sur l'article 1er sur les
territoires de santé avec cet article
nous redonnons la main à l'ensemble des
acteurs du territoire pour porter
ensemble un diagnostic et des solutions
en faveur de l'accès aux soins dans une
logique graduée de responsabilisation
des acteurs c'est toute l'ambition de
cette mesure qui s'inscrit parfaitement
dans la dynamique du CNR que nous avons
lancé l'année
dernière sur l'article 3 et les CPTs je
sais par ailleurs que votre assemblée
légitimement sensible à la nécessité
pour les professionnels de santé de
mieux se coordonner notamment via les
CPTs à l'initiative du groupe
Renaissance les professionnels de la
santé scolaire pourront désormais
intégrer ces structures c'est un apport
bienvenu notre objectif c'est bien de
permettre à tous les patients quel que
soit le territoire dans lequel il réside
de pouvoir bénéficier des missions que
les CPTs mettent en œuvre d'ici à la fin
de l'année une grande partie aura été
réalisée avec près de 85 % de la
population couverte soit plus de 20
points gagnés en moins d'un an nous nous
approchons donc de notre objectif de 100
% de couverture il nous faut poursuivre
notre travail d'information et
d'accompagnement de tous les
professionnels sur le terrain pour
promouvoir ces
CPTs cela rejoint un autre enjeu pour
lequel ce texte apporte des mesures
utiles celui de donner envie à nos
étudiants de s'installer dans les
territoires sans tous les citer je pense
à l'extension du bénéfice du CESP aux
étudiants en odotologie en maillotique
et en pharmacie dès la 2e année une
mesure utile demandée par plusieurs
groupes de votre assemblée
je pense également à l'expérimentation
visant à encourager dans les lycées
situés en zone Soudans l'orientation des
élèves vers les métiers de la santé qui
était une demande conjointe de plusieurs
bans il nous faut mobiliser tous les
leviers et ces mesures vont dans le bon
sens parce que mieux articuler l'offre
de formation et les besoins des
territoires est une préoccupation
majeure l'article 5 bis de ce texte
prévoit la prise en compte des besoins
des territoires en priorité puis des
capacités de formation le le
gouvernement entend et partage cette
volonté de prendre en compte les besoins
spécifiques des territoires nous avons
d'ailleurs eu ce débat jeudi dernier
lors de l'examin de la proposition de
loi du député Yannick Nder et je tiens à
le redire les capacités de formation des
universités restent une réalité qu'il
nous faut impérativement prendre en
compte en matière de renforcement de la
formation parce que les sujets sont bien
évidamment lié il nous faut mieux
prendre en compte la sécurité de la
santé physique et mentale des internes
en stage ce sera désormais dans la loi
grâce à un ajout de Stéphanie riste
prendre soin de ceux qui nous soignent
est un impératif qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur concernant les
certificats infirmiers j'aimerais dire
quelques mots sur l'article 2 quc qui
élargit l'expérimentation des
certificats de décès par les infirmiers
à l'ensemble du territoire national le
Gouvernement partage bien entendu la
volonté d'avancer sur ce sujet essentiel
si je comprends la volonté voir
l'impatience du législateur je souhaite
rappeler que le décret et les arrêtés
permettant d'engager la mise en œuvre de
l'expérimentation sur six régions pris
en application de la LFSS pour 2023 ont
été publiés jeudi 7 décembre dernier le
travail a été important avec l'ensemble
des acteurs durant cette année pour
préparer le déploiement dans les
meilleures conditions de cette
expérimentation
complexe ce nouveau vote moins d'un an
après entraînant une extension de
l'expérimentation à l'ensemble du
territoire non plus sur du FIR mais sur
de long d'AM risque de poser des
problématiques opérationnelles nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion d'en discuter
je voudrais revenir enfin sur les
apports de ce texte concernant les padus
ce texte et je m'en réjouis
particulièrement prolonge notre ambition
de simplification du parcours
d'autorisation des professionnels de
santé à diplôme hors Union Européenne
dit Pasu le dispositif de cette
proposition de loi permettra d'apporter
davantage de souplesse dans la
réalisation des stages de consolidation
des compétences en modulant la durée de
de stage requise elle pourra désormais
être limitée à 6 mois ce sont des
parcours plus lisibles pour les Padu et
une réponse améliorée pour l'accès aux
soins je salue d'ailleurs les apports
lors de la navette concernant les Padu
outrem vers une simplification et une
plus grande reconnaissance de la
contribution essentielle des praticiens
dans ces
territoires le gouvernement accueille
donc favorablement les mesures de ce
texte issues des travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire car oui comme
le rappelle et l'a rappelé le rapporteur
ce texte fait œuvre utile avec comme
valeur cardinale la solidarité entre les
territoires et les acteurs et la
confiance envers les professionnel je
vous remercie je vous remercie donc nous
pouvons entamer la discussion générale
et le premier orateur c'est Monsieur
Jean-François
[Applaudissements]
Roussé
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier monsieur le
rapporteur Frédéric valetou car grâce à
son important travail de négociation au
côté de la rapporteur sénatrice Corine
ber nous sommes parvenus à une CMP
conclusive sur un texte qui propose des
mesures en faveur de l'accès aux soins
je ne vouis pas vous rappeler le constat
selon lequel l'accès au soins est
difficile mais je tiens par contre à
vous rappeler que notre majorité est
engagé pour l'amélioration de l'accès
aux soins depuis maintenant 6 ans nous
avons légiféré pour transformer
simplifier et améliorer le modèle de
soin notamment par le développement des
exercices coordonnés des délégations de
compétences l'instauration de la 4e
année interna pour valider la spécialité
de médecine générale c'est donc en
continuuité que nous avons travaillé sur
ce texte nous avons proposé de
véritables avancées en construction avec
le rapporteur ce travail nous a permis
d'aboutir un texte pragmatique et
méthodique tout d'abord nous souhaitons
créer des voocation chez les jeunes afin
qu'ils s'engage qu'ils s'engagent dans
les études de santé c'est à l'unanimité
que notre Assemblée a retenu
l'expérimentation permettant d'instaurer
des options santé dans les lycées c'est
un modèle que j'ai développé dans ma
circonscription et qui fonctionne depuis
la rentrée 2023 je tiens donc à saluer
cette avancée ensuite notre groupe
apporter et soutenu la création du
statut d'infirmier référent ce point
était maintenu dans le texte issu de la
CMP et permet de créer une véritable un
véritable triptique autour du patient au
côté du médecin traitant du pharmacien
correspondant l'infirmier référent
jouera donc pleinement son rôle dans la
prévention et le suivi du patient en
outre nous sommes parvenu à un compromis
satisfaisant permettant d'engager la
responsabilité collective des
établissements de S santé à la
permanence des soins les cliniques et
les hôpitaux seront mobilisés pour y
participer sans instaurer une obligation
de garde le texte actuel garanti au
directeurs généraux des ARS des pouvoirs
gradués leur permettant d'intervenir en
cas de carence à la permanence des soins
c'est également notre groupe qui a
permis d'écarter l'interdiction de
l'intérim médical en début de carrière
certes nous l'avons affirmé le modèle
intérimaire n'a pas vocation à être
celui de la garantie d'une offre de so
est stable et continue pour les
étudiants l'intérim permet toutefois de
financer une partie de leurs études
c'est pourquoi nous nous fa félicitons
de cette limite à
l'interdiction le texte adopté en CMP
est donc un texte de compromis qui a
permis de conserver les mesures
progressives progressistes votées au
sein de cette Assemblée tout en
maintenant la ligne rouge inacceptable
pour nous de la
coertion en effet ce texte
responsabilise les professionnels de
santéans sans les contraindre il permet
le développement de l'exercice coordonné
sans pour autant les enferm enfermer les
praticiens il propose une conciliation
entre les droits d'accès aux soins dont
doivent jouir les patients et les
aspirations légitimes des professionnels
de santé à bénéficier de meilleures
conditions de travail en conséquence le
groupe Renaissance votera pour cette loi
merci je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Thierry frappé
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
madame
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général madame la
Présidente de commission mes chers
collègues à chaque semaine sa loi
portant sur la réforme de santé de notre
territoire et plus particulièrement
cette fois une loi portant sur l'accès
aux soins pour nos concitoyens
8 millions c'est le chiffre à retenir 8
millions c'est le nombre de Français
vivant dans un désert médical après la
loi présentée par notre collègue Éric
Neder jeudi dernier nous avons enfin
avancer dans l'accès aux soins pour nos
concitoyens je tiens tout d'abord à
remercier no collègues du Sénat et
Madame Corine Ambert rapporteur au Sénat
en effet ce texte partait de loin la
commission des Affaires social du Sénat
a considérablement amélioré votre texte
monsieur le rapporteur en reprenant de
nombreuses propositions que mon groupe
le rassemblement national a pu proposer
en première
lecture même si initialement vous avez
contredit notre point de vue la version
initiale de ce texte venait ajouter une
surcharge administrative sur nos
professionnel de santé je tiens à
rappeler que de nombreux professionnels
de santé n'exercent plus tout simplement
leur art à titre d'exemple dans mon
département nous sommes proches de 50 %.
cette surcharge administrative
représente près de 30 % du temps de
travail pour les professionnels de santé
et entre dans les motifs donc d'abandon
de la profession votre loi étaé taxée
sur trois
thématiques d'abord la création d'un
conseil territorial de santé pour
responsabiliser les professionnels de
santé en matière d'égalité aux soins
avec cette article on risquait de se
défausser de la responsabilité de votre
majorité faisant porter le point ainsi
de la désertification médicale sur les
professionnels de santé en leur donnant
la lourde responsabilité de déterminer
les conditions d'acè d'égalité d'accès
aux soins qui n'est pas au départ la
profession initiale de de ces de ces
professionnels ensuite le rattachement
de tous les professionnels de santé au
CPTs de façon
automatique les communautés
professionnelles territoriales de santé
or un tel rattachement aurait enfermé
l'exercice libéral et aurait ajouté une
nouvelle charge administrative au
médecins enfin la souplissement des
conditions d'exercice pour les médecins
étrangers sur le territoire national C
article directement inspiré de l'article
7 du projet de loi immigration morné
constate l'inopérance de la politique
gouvernementale en matière de santé et
vient privé certains pays de leurs
forces vives en matière médical nous
nous félicitons toutefois de la
nonadoption du dispositif contraignant
menaçant la liberté
d'installation mais aussi de la
suppression de cette adhésion
automatique au CPTs le le Sénat est
également revenu sur les obligations
d'astreinte de garde et la
responsabilité repose maintenant sur les
établissements et non les professionnel
nous pourrions dire
victoire monsieur le rapporteur je vous
le dis de nouveau diminuer la liberté de
nos professionnels de santé nuira à
terme sur l'offre de soins sur le
territoire national cette loi présente
Infiné des avancées
intéressantes l'instauration d'un délai
minimal de 10 ans pour qu'un
professionnel de santé puisse bénéficier
à nouveau d'aide à l'installation ou
d'exonération
fiscale la place de l'infirmier référent
l'extension de l'expérimentation de la
signature des certificat de décès pour
les infirmiers et la modification des
conditions de financement le recul de la
limite d'âge du cumulle emploi retraite
pour certains professionnels de santé ou
encore la suppression de la majoration
du ticket modérateur à l'encontre de
certains patients dépourvus de médecins
traitants toujours est-il que notre
groupe fidèle à sa politique démontre
qu'il s'engage pour l'intérêt général
l'intérêt des Français bien
qu'imparfaite cette loi va améliorer
l'offre de soins et l'accès aux soins de
nos compatriotes le rassemblement
nationale votera donc en faveur de cette
loi je vous
remercie merci la parole est maintenant
à Madame
[Applaudissements]
mathildeign
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
depuis un an et demi de permanence en
permanence toujours les mêmes
inquiétudes qui reviennent mobilité
logement hausse des prix santé pouvoir
être soigné correctement à une distance
raisonnable de son domicile devient de
plus en plus compliqué en Bretagne la
moitié des communes ne comptait aucun
médecin en 2021 en France 11 % des
patients de 17 ans et plus n'ont pas de
médecins traitant cela correspond à peu
près à 6 millions de nos concitoyens
dont 600000 personnes en affection
longue durée face à cette situation
cette proposition semblait bienvenue
nous avons formuler des propositions
concrètes pour l'enrichir notamment avec
le travail le groupe de travail
transpartisan sur les déserts médicaux
initiés par notre collègue Guillaume
Garot le travail parlementaire que nous
avons mené dans cet hémicycle en juin
dernier aurait aura permis d'apporter
certaines améliorations pour avancer
vers l'égalité d'accès aux soins partout
en France l'ouverture du contrat
d'engagement au service public dès la 2e
année du premier cycle des études de
santé la suppression de la majoration
tarifaire pour les patients qui n'ont
pas de médecin traitant c'est quand même
dommage que ce soit juste pour une durée
d'un an et que les patients qui n'ont
déjà pas de médecin traitant ne soient
pas pris en compte tant que le problème
de manque de personnel de professionnel
sur certains territoires ne sera pas
résolu les gens continueront à avoir des
difficultés d'accès aux
soins nous regrettons qu'un grand nombre
de mesures ure que nous portions dans ce
texte est été balayé au Sénat et la
commission mixte paritaire n'a pas
permis de les réintégrer le rattachement
de tous les professionnels de santé au
CPTs supprimé la la participation de
l'ensemble des médecins à la permanence
de soins supprimé aujourd'hui seul
seulement un tiers des médecins
participent à la permanence des soins
c'est pourtant un acte d'intérêt général
qui repose sur trop peu de
personnes la possibilité de salarier les
médecins par les ARS supprimé rien pour
renforcer le financement public des
postes salariés de médecins dans les
territoires où la situation est la plus
dégradée ni pour accélérer le
développement des centres de santé
publiqu le développement du salariat
dans les maisons de santé en régie
constitue pourtant une alternative
solide c'est ce qu'affirme la la Cour
des comptes dans son rapport annuel de
2023 et l'indicateur territorial de
l'offre de soin que nous avions voté
dans cet hémicycle a été vidé de sa
substance il devait permettre de
déterminer l'écart entre le besoin total
et le besoin et le besoin couvert sur
chaque territoire c'est devenu un
rapport illisible dont on ne pourra rien
faire résultat cette proposition de loi
reste marquée par son manque d'ambition
rien dans ce texte ne permettra de
résoudre la problématique des déserts
médicaux c'est l'enchaînement d'années
d'inaction dégradant dégradant notre
système de santé qui a conduit
l'association des consommateurs UFC Que
Choisir à accusé votre gouvernement
d'inaction parM parmis les mesures que
l'association sollicite pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins la régulation de
l'installation des médecins 74 % des
Français plébiscite cette application
son
application une mesure que nous avions
proposé à l'occasion de l'examen de ce
texte avec le groupe de travail
transpartisan bien loin d'être
coercitive la régulation est un outil
indispensable à la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux pour répondre aux
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens qui se
rendent chaque semaine dans nos
permanences pour témoigner de la
dégradation du système de santé nous
nous continuerons à proposer des mesures
concrètes démocratisation de l'accès aux
études de santé revalorisation urgente
des rémunérations amélioration des
conditions de travail des soignants et
des
soignantes d'ailleurs à l'approche des
fêes j'ai une pensée particulière pour
les professionnels de santé qui risquent
de faire face à des fermetures de
services et à une augmentation de la
charge de travail si cette proposition
de loi nous a permis d'avoir un débat
sur la médecine de ville à l'Assemblée
nous sommes encore loin d'engager la
grande réforme dont notre système de
santé a cruellement besoin sans pour
autant renier les avancées construites
ensemble dans l'exercice parlementaire
il nous faut tenir compte de l'équilibre
général du texte en net recul suite à
l'examen au Sénat c'est pourquoi notre
groupe votera contre ce texte je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Yanni
noer
madame la présidente madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente de commission mes
chers collègues je nécessit de le dire
ici même à cette tribune notre pays
subit une pénurie de professionnelle de
santé et particulièrement de médecin oui
une pénurie il n'y a pas d'autres mots
pour qualifier la situation alarmante de
la démographie médicale en France qui
met en péril notre système de santé et
l'accès aux soins je rappelle quelques
chiffres que nous connaissons tous 30 %
des Français vivent dans un désert
médical et 11 % soit 6 millions de nos
concitoyens n'ont pas de médecins
traitant dont 600000 en affection longue
durée vous l'avez compris nous arrivons
dans une impasse avec pour effet une
dégradation considérable de l'accès aux
soins pour nos concitoyens mes chers
collègues il est donc attendu que le
législateur s'empare de l'ampleur du
problème pour y apporter des réponses
solides et pérennes c'est dans cette
dynamique que nous avons tous ensemble
adopté ici même la semaine dernière ma
proposition de loi visant à former plus
de médecins je m'en réjouis pour les
Français et je vous remercie à nouveau
de m'avoir suivi au-delà de toute
couleur politique mais aujourd'hui je me
réjouis que le texte de Monsieur Valtou
dont les conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire font l'objet de notre
discussion traite également de cette
question de comment améliorer l'accès
aux soins des Fran français car en c'est
en effet au terme des discussions
constructives au service de la santé des
Français que le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale se sont entendus sur une
rédaction commune pour avoir participé à
ces discussions je vous le dis cette
rédaction commune honore tant le travail
de Monsieur Frédéric Valtou à
l'Assemblée nationale que je remercie
que celui de Madame Corine Ambert au
Sénat que je remercie également les
républicains nous sommes donc satisfaits
de cette nouvelle rédaction à laquelle
nous avons largement contribué attentive
aux réalités du terrain et gage d'un
consensus qui pourtant apparaissait
impossible enre entre nos deux chambres
il y a encore quelques semaine mon
expérience de médecin l'hôpital public
et d'élu local fait que je sais au
combien notre système de santé est à
bout de souffle et au combien la menace
de la désertification médicale est
grande touchant particulièrement la
ruralité aujourd'hui en tant que député
je salue notre capacité à travailler
ensemble pour trouver des solutions face
à cette menace et afin d'en limiter les
conséquences pour nos
concitoyens lorsque je dis ensemble
j'inclus l'ensemble des acteurs qui ont
participé à la rédaction finale de ce
texte parmi lesquels naturellement les
professionnels de santé si nous avons
réussi à intégrer leur revendication
majeure dans le texte ils prennent part
à ce consensus car car encore plus que
nous ils sont animés par une vocation
celle d'améliorer l'accès aux soins en
France et à nouveau je les remercie pour
leur engagement car en effet mes chers
collègues mon expérience que j'évoquais
précédemment me fait dire qu'en l'état
actuel des choses c'est-à-dire fortement
des
la coerition prévue initialement dans le
texte nous aurait été contre-productive
dans la mesure où elle aurait menacé
l'attractivité des métiers du soins et
donc de l'accès aux soins à moyen et
long terme aussi je reste convaincu que
nous devons plutôt renforcer nos
politiques publiques pour améliorer
cette attractivité notamment au travers
d'initiatives portées par les
collectivités toriales très engagé
contre la désertification médicale
aujourd'hui grâce à cette CMP le texte
va dans le bon sens c'est pourquoi les
républicains en approuvant désormais met
le contenu et nous voterons
favorablement ce texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Nicolas
[Applaudissements]
turcois
madame la
présidente madame monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
le groupe démocrate se félicite de
l'accord en commission mixte paritaire
conclu jeudi dernier entre notre
assemblée et le Sénat il témoigne de
l'importance de la navette parlementaire
entre les deux chambres du Parlement
mais également de notre capacité à
parvenir à un compromis nous avons été
élus pour apporter des réponses aux
préoccupations des Français notamment en
matière d'accès à la santé il est de
notre responsabilité de réussir à
négocier aussi difficile que cela soit
parfois le texte de compromis dont notre
assemblée est saisie est le fruit de
cette
exigence je tiens donc à remercier
l'ensemble des parlementaires ayant
participer à la commission mixte
paritaire pour leur écoute et leur
attitude constructive à l'heure où 6
millions de personnes sont sans médecin
traitant il était urgent
d'agir ne nous mprenons pas sur les
ambitions de ce texte il ne permettra
pas de résoudre le problème de la
désertification médicale de façon
magique seule une chose le pourrait
davantage de professionnels de santé
dans nos campagnes dans nos banlieux
dans nos territoires ultramarins or les
médecins les chirurgiens dentistes ou
les sages-femmes mettent de nombreuses
années à se former peut-être trop
d'ailleurs j'aimerais que ça soit
expertisé en attendant cette
augmentation de l'offre de soins à
laquelle la réforme du numéreus closusus
décidé en 2019 contribuera de façon
significative une autre voie était
possible pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins
à l'initiative du député Guillaume Garot
et de mon ancien collègue Philippe
Vigier désormais ministre des outrm une
proposition de loi transpartisane Cigné
par plus de 200 parlementaires dont une
vingtaine du groupe démocrate avait été
déposé allait-elle résoudre toutes les
difficultés pour se soigner de nos
compatriotes non bien évidemment
proposait-elle des pistes innovantes et
volontaires face à l'urgence de la
situation oui manifestement pour autant
elle n'a pas été inscrite à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée pour l'instant le
groupe démocrate se félicite néanmoins
que plusieurs de ces dispositions a fait
l'objet d'un accord lors de l'examen en
séance publique à l'Assemblée je pense
par exemple au renforcement du rôle du
guichet unique dans l'accompagnement des
professionnels de santé pour les
décharger autant que faire ce peut des
formalités administratives ou à
l'ouverture du contrat d'engagement du
service public dès la 2e année pour que
davantage de jeunes de milieu modeste
soient soutenus financièrement pendant
leurs études et a ensuite exercer dans
un désert médical ou encore à la
limitation de l'intérêt en début de
carrière pour inciter à la
titularisation des jeunes
diplômés désormais riche de 35 articles
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
Frédéric Valtou présente au final de
nombreuses dispositions qui vont dans le
bon sens pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins nous saluons les avancés je
pourrais citer le recentrage de la
gouvernance locale en santé autour des
conseils territoriaux de santé les cts
le renforcement de la participation des
hôpitaux à la permanence des soins les
gardes la création d'une autorisation
temporaire d'exercice pour les
praticiens diplômés hors de l'Union
Européenne les fameux Pasu une meilleure
prise en compte des besoins du
territoire dans la détermination des
capacités d'accueil des universités en
santé dont nous débattions justement la
semaine dernière mais également diverses
mesures d'amélioration de l'accès au
soins parce qu'elle contraignne très
modérément les professionnels de santé
ou qu'elle vise à les soutenir dans leur
exercice médical ou même qu'ell
permettent de faire évoluer la
gouvernance et le contrôle en matière de
santé nous pensons cependant que nous
devrions aller plus loin pour renforcer
l'égalité territoriale d'accès aux soins
l'une des propositions de la PPL
transpartisane contre les déserts
médicaux visait ainsi à faire évoluer
les conditions d'installation des
médecins et des chirurgiens dentistes le
principe est simple dans les zones qui
ne souffre pas de difficultés d'accès
aux soins par exemple les centr-villes
des villes côtières du sud de la France
ou le 16e arrondissement de Paris un
médecin souhaitant s'installer devrait
nécessairement remplacer un autre c'est
ce qu'on appelle le plaque à plaque
l'installation sera demeuré complètement
libre partout ailleurs c'est-à-dire dans
l'immense majorité du reste du
territoire l'exercice de praticien de
santé diplômé hors de l'Union Européenne
gagnerait également être développé c'est
ce que proposait la version transmise au
Sénat cette proposition de loi à travers
la création d'une carte de séjour
pluriannuelle pour les professions
médicales et de la
pharmacie à court terme notre priorité
doit être de réussir à économiser du
temps médical par la coopération entre
professionnelle par le recours à des
assistants et par une ambitieuse
politique de prévention c'est toute
l'ambition du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 en complément de ces mesures le
group démocrate votera en faveur des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire toute disposition visant à
améliorer l'accès aux soins do être
soutenu et ce texte en comporte
plusieurs j'en félicite encore monsieur
le rapporteur je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant à
monsieur Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
Garot
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues chaque jour
des dizaines des centaines de nos
concitoyens perdent leur médecin
traitant sans pouvoir le remplacer
chaque
jour un territoire perd le seul talmo le
seul ginico le seul dermato qui lui
restait et concrètement sur le terrain
vous le savez ce sont des soins qui sont
retardés ce sont des urgences qui sont
engorgées ce sont des pertes de chance
qui sont avérées et à chaque fois c'est
la promesse
républicaine de la santé pour tous qui
est foulé au pied ne pas agir c'est
laisser dans nos territoires prospérer
un sentiment d'abandon qui tôt ou tard
profitera à une extrême droite qui ne
propose rien et qui surtout face au
déserts médicaux ne veut rien changer
pour gagner la bienveillance de certains
lobby médicaux et c'est d'abord contre
ce sentiment d'abandon et de fatalisme
que nous devons
lutter c'est pour cette raison que nous
sommes ici quelques-uns et de plus en
plus nombreux convaincus que la
régulation de l'installation fait partie
des leviers à actionner c'est ce qui
manque dans la loi et c'est pour nous la
marque de
l'inefficacité du gouvernement alors
nous examinons ce texte présenté par
Frédéric Valtou et je veux le dire nous
sommes déçus la version qui était issue
du vote en première lecture à
l'Assemblée ici avait euh posé quelques
progrès et je veux d'ailleurs saluer
l'esprit d'ouverture et d'écoute du
rapporteur ce qui est vrai aujourd'hui
ce soir au terme du cheminement
parlementaire et de la CMP en
particulier c'est que nous avons obtenu
des mesures et quand je dis nous c'est
non seulement députés socialistes que je
représente mais beaucoup ici qui sont
membres du groupe transpartisan que j'ai
l'honneur et le plaisir
d'animer et nous espérons que ces
mesures auront un impact réel dans la
lutte pour l'accès au soins alors je
veux les rappeler pour mémoire même si
ça a été rappelé c'est l'extension du
CESP dès la 2e année pour que aucun
jeune de conditions modestes ne soit
empêché de devenir médecin c'est
l'obligation de préavis de 6 mois pour
un praticien qui voudrait quitter son
cabinet c'est la suppression de la
majoration des tarifs pour les patients
qui n'ont plus de médecin traitant c'est
la limitation du cumule des aides à
l'installation face aux chasseurs de
prime mais et il y a un grand mais la
CMP a détricooté un grand nombre de
dispositions auxquelles nous tenions
exite la participation obligatoire des
généraliste à la permanence des soins
exite l'indicateur territorial de
l'offre de soins qui a été vidé de sa
substance exite le financement de postes
salariés en désert médical par les ARS
et donc au final la la version qui est
issue de la CMP contient trop de recul
pour que nous puissions nous prononcer
favorablement sur ce texte et donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous députés
socialistes nous
abstiendrons alors je veux le dire pour
pour conclure nous aurons d'autres
rendez-vous parlementaire et nous
continuerons dans la diversité de ce que
nous représentons
pour que la
République garantisse de nouveau
l'égalité de tous face à la santé c'est
le sens de notre combat et nous
continuerons de le mener je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur François
[Applaudissements]
Gernigon
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis
pour voter définitivement sur la
proposition de loi portée par le groupe
horizon et apparenté un texte qui marque
un tournant dans notre approche de la
santé
publique cette loi initié par notre
collègue Frédéric Valtou est une réponse
audacieuse et nécessaire au défi de
l'accès aux soins dans notre pays
faisant suite aux travaux conjoints
engagés avec le gouvernement et de
l'investissement de notre groupe sur ce
sujet depuis le début de la
législature l'essence de cette
proposition réside dans son ambition de
transformer l'organisation territoriale
des soins en France
elle envisage une coopération renforcée
entre les différents acteurs qu'il soit
issu du secteur libéral public privé ou
même des patients et des élus
locaux cette approche est cruciale pour
adresser les enjeux complexes de notre
système de santé en plaçant le conseil
territorial de santé au centre de la
gouvernance cette loi fait un pas
audacieux elle reconnaît l'importance de
contextualiser les soins de santé en les
ancrant fermement dans les réalités et
les besoins spécifiques de chaque
territoire ce n'est qu'en comprenant et
en répondant à ces besoins locaux que
nous pouvons véritablement améliorer
l'accès aux soins pour tous pour tous
les Français la loi propose également
des avancées significatives dans le
secteur hospitalier elle encourage une
participation plus équilibrée à la
permanence des soins dans les
établissements de santé et vise à mieux
réguler l'intérim médical
particulièrement en début de carrière de
plus elle facilite l'intégration des
patriciens diplômés hors de l'Union
européenne une mesure qui pourrait
s'avérer cruciale pour combler les
lacunes en matière de personnel
médical en complémentarité avec la loi
pour l'amélioration de l'accès au soins
porté par Stéphanie Rist promulgué en
mai dernier cette proposition de loi
continue de réformer notre système de
santé avec une approche résolument
territoriale il est important de Notter
que la construction de ce texte a permis
des avancées notables comme la
suppression de la Major des soins pour
les patients sans médecin traitant la
création du statut d'infirmier référent
et la capacité qu' leurait donné de
réaliser des actes de décès pour les
volontaires ou encore l'instauration
d'un préavis de 6 mois des médecins
quittant un
territoire la commission mixte paritaire
du 7 décembre 2023 a montré une volonté
transpartisane des deux chambres de
faire avancer cette proposition de loi
enrichie par la navette parlementaire
cela témoigne de notre engagement commun
à trouver des solutions pour l'une des
préoccupations majeures des Français la
santé et l'accès aux
soins cette proposition de loi
transcende les frontières partisanes
pour devenir le fruit d'un effort
collectif et coopératif
elle a été enrichie notamment grâce à
une collaboration étroite avec le groupe
transpartisan sur les déserts médicaux
piloté par notre collègue Guillaume
Garot cette synergie reflète notre
engagement commun a dépasser les
divergences politiques en faveur d'un
objectif supérieur assurer l'équité et
l'accessibilité des soins pour chaque
citoyen français il est important de
reconnaître que malgré des désaccords
l'essentiel demeure notre détermination
unanime à mobiliser toutes les bonnes
volontés pour adopter des mesures
significatives et
efficaces pour conclure je tiens à
souligner que cette proposition de loi
ne représente pas seulement une réforme
législative mais une vision pour
l'avenir de la santé en France elle
reconnaît que l'amélioration de l'accès
aux soins passe par une coopération
étroite entre tous les professionnels de
la santé et par une approche qui prend
racine dans les spécificités de chaque
territoire c'est une étape vers un
système de santé plus efficace et
réactif aux besoins de tous nos
concitoyens je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Sébastien
péavi
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous voilà à nouveau réunis
aujourd'hui pour discuter d'une des
principales préoccupations des
Françaises et des Français l'accès aux
soins ce Bien Public inaliénable qui la
santé est aujourd'hui quotidienne menacé
par une offre de soins insuffisante
inégalement répartie et en proie à la
privatisation dans un tel contexte que
dire de cette proposition de loi qui
brille finalement aujourd'hui par un
manque de courage un manque de courage
notamment sur la question de la
permanence des soins alors que ce texte
issu de la CMP a supprimé l'article 4
bis qui rétablissait l'obligation de
participation à la permanence des soins
au-delà de la simple mention de respons
abilité collective si le texte prévoit
que les établissements de santé privé
auront bien à répondre à la mission de
permanence des soins comment expliquer
aux habitants des zones soudanses que
les médecins généralistes ne seront eux
toujours pas obligés de participer au
garde nous rappelons que seulement 38 %
des médecins généralistes participe à la
permanence des soins et ce taux était de
73 % en 2012 si si les médecins ne
participent pas à leur mission de
service public de la santé nous
pousserons les courageux à
l'épuisement dans un contexte de pénurie
manifeste nous avons besoin de la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs de la
santé selon leurs compétences pour
répondre au mieux à la permanence des
soins cela implique nécessairement de
prendre la question de la régulation de
l'offre à bras le corps et affronter
sans sans tabout les défis auxquels nous
sommes confrontés car inciter les
professionnel de santé exténué a
travaillé jusqu'à 72 ans pour palier 40
ans d'inaction politique néant rien une
réponse courageuse à la crise que nous
traversons et à ce sujet nous regrettons
que l'examen de cette proposition de loi
soit à nouveau une occasion manquée pour
lever le tabou sur la liberté
d'installation des médecins généralistes
ce texte n'aura en effet qu'une portée
partielle s'il priorise la liberté
d'installation des médecins au détriment
des besoins de santé de la population
dans un contexte où 6,7 million de
personnes n'ont pas de médecins traitant
nous n'avons plus le temps pour la
demi-mesure nous devons faire preuve de
lucidité garantir un accès égal aux
soins pour toutes et tous qu'importe son
lieu de vie ne pourra se faire sans
opérer une répartition la plus juste
poss possible des médecins généralistes
sur notre territoire et cela passe
nécessairement par la régulation de
l'installation des médecins au même
titre que les infirmières les
pharmaciens et cette solution s'imposera
de fait avec le temps nous tion pourtant
d'un texte certes imparfait et
améliorable mais qui proposait quelques
avancées notables telles que Cell
faisant du territoire de santé l'échelon
privilégié du pilotage des politiques de
santé d'accès aux soins ou la création
d'un guichet d'accompagnement à
destination des professionnels de santé
et certes la CMP il faut quand même le
préciser composé de SEP médecins a
conservé certaines dispositions tels que
le préavis de 6 mois en cas de départ
d'un médecin généraliste mais en l'état
nous manque comp de garantie dans un
contexte où nous le rappelons la
démographie médicale ne trouvera pas un
niveau minimal avant 10 ans cette CMP a
ainsi perdu son objectif de vue à savoir
celui d'apporter une réponse ambitieuse
au territoire abandonné par les services
publics de la santé car sans médecins
généraliste et sans service public de la
santé nous ouvrons la porte à une santé
à deux vitesses et des inégalité entre
territoires toujours plus fortes ce
texte n'offre qu'une réponse
insuffisante pour mettre fin à la
malsine entre les territoires entre ceux
qui ont les moyens et les autres il
n'amorce toujours pas de sortie pas la
sortie du même modèle qui nous a plongé
dans cette pénurie de médecin ce texte
en l'état n'est malheureusement plus
qu'un échantillon de sa version initiale
un échantillon qui manque encore
cruellement de vision sur la santé de
santé que nous voulons garantir à la
population et auquel nous ne pourrons
donc souscrire le groupe écologiste
s'abstiendra je vous remercie la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
Présidente de commission monsieur le
rapporteur ça a été dit près de 87 % du
territoire est un désert médical qu'il
s'agisse des grandes agglomérations ou
des campagnes il n'est pas besoin
d'égrainer de nouveau les chiffres ceux
des patients sans médecin traitant des
délis d'attente hors du commun pour
obtenir un rendez-vous chez un
spécialiste ceux de la densité médicale
ceux des services d'urgence qui
fonctionnent en mode dégradé ceux du
reste à charge exorbitant pour les
personnes ayant la chance d'intégrer un
épad ou encore le taux de mortalité
néonatale qui nous place désormais au
20e rang européen il n'est pas davantage
nécessaire de rappeler les milliards
d'euros qui manquent pour les hôpitaux
et les établissements sociaux et
médicos-sociaux pour qu'ils sortent au
moins d'un déficit structurel
ce n'est pas nécessaire de le rappeler
car nous le savons tous et nous y sommes
quotidiennement rappelés dans nos
territoires notre problème qui est
d'abord celui de tous les Français c'est
que ce gouvernement n' veut rien savoir
de cette réalité devenue scandaleuse de
l'accès au soins dans notre pays pour la
deè année consécutive ce gouvernement a
privé la représentation nationale d'un
débat sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale aucune loi structurelle de santé
publique ne nous a été soumise et sera a
priori ex c'est dans ce contexte que
l'association EFC Que Choisir à fort à
propos saisi le 21 novembre dernier le
Conseil d'État pour faire constater et
sanctionner la coupable inaction
gouvernementale et enjoindre l'État à
prendre les mesures à la hauteur des
enjeux cette proposition de loi de nos
collègues du groupe Renaissance et du
groupe Horizon est loin d'inverser la
donne dès son titre cette proposition de
loi semble en effet vouloir faire peser
sur les seuls professionnels de santé la
situation sitation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui exonérant l'état de ses
propres responsabilités or c'est
précisément d'une politique de santé
publique globale dont nous avons besoin
et que les professionnels de santé ont
besoin aussi brandir la
territorialisation en exumant les
conseils territoriaux de santé comme une
réponse magique ne sert à rien quels
moyens seront attribués à l'animation
territoriale de ces conseil territoriaux
de santé nous doutons également toujours
de la simplification de l'Organisation
Locale de S
que nous que vous nous promettez quelle
sera l'articulation entre les projets
régionaux de santé les projets
territoriaux de santé des cts et les
projets médicaux et médicos-sociaux
d'établissement au périmètres
géographiques différents avec des
objectifs contractuels définis avec des
tutelles distinctes en outre toutes les
mesures qui visaient à réguler le flux
d'installation des médecins et qui est
pourtant déjà une réalité pour la
plupart des autres professions santé ont
été systématiquement repoussé par
ailleurs le Sénat puis la CMP ont
largement réduit les propositions
visantes initialement à renforcer la
participation à la permanence des soins
il ne demeure qu'une demi-mesure en
joignant les établissements publics et
privés à participer à la permanence des
soins selon que les carences constatées
sont ou non persistantes certes quelques
mesures allant dans le bon sens ont pu
se glisser par-ci par là dans le texte
la création d'un nouvel indicateur
territorial de l'offre de soins la mise
en place d'un préavis pour les
professionnels quittant leur F
la disposition Visante à mieux protéger
la santé physique et psychique des
internes en médecine mais au regard de
l'urgence actuelle la seule question que
nous devons nous poser est cette
organisation locale de la santé
aura-t-elle un effet bénéfique pour les
patients auront-il un rendez-vous
médical dans les délais enfin
acceptables auront-ils accès dans de
meilleurs délais aux spécialistes
nécessaires la coordination de leur
parcours de soins s'en trouvera-t-elle
conforté
nous sommes bien dans l'incapacité de le
dire car à aucun moment cette
proposition de loi dépourvue d'étude
d'impact et de budget n'a ét en capacité
de le démontrer pour toutes ces raisons
les députés communistes et ultramarins
du groupe GDR ne soutiendront pas ce
texte en matière de santé publique nous
légiférons toujours à la marge de ce que
sont les problématiques d'accès aux
soins rencontrés par nos
concitoyens mais madame la ministre et
vous le direz à Monsieur le Ministre
s'il vous
plaît il faudra bien un jour avoir le
courage de revisiter le système
d'installation des médecins afin que les
professionnels soient contraints de
répondre aux besoins de santé de notre
pays il faudra bien revisiter l'accès et
le coût de cette formation notamment les
coûts annexes qui écarte des étudiants
et admettre le besoin d'une prise en
charge totale des études moyennant une
contrepartie d'exercice dans un
territoire en souffrance autant
d'exemples qui nous invitent à repenser
la dichotomie persistante entre un mode
libéral d'exercice et une prise en
charge publique et solidaire de la santé
il y a urgence de répondre aux besoins
de santé de notre pays je vous
remercie alors avant de donner la parole
au dernier orateur je vous indique que
sur le vote du texte de la CMP je suis
saisie par le groupe horizon apparenté
d'une demande de scrutin public qui est
annoncée dans notre enceinte et la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Laurent
panifous
ci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues la désertification
médical est un sujet qui nous réunit
tous il ne se passe pas un jour sans que
nous constas à quel point il s'aggrave à
quel point nous ne parvenons pas à
garantir le principe constitutionnel
d'égal accès aux soins partout et pour
tous ce constat est celui d'un échec
collectif fruit de décennies de
décisions inadaptées ou insuffisantes au
sein de notre groupe nous considérons
que face à la désertification médicale
il n'y a pas de solution miracle c'est
un arsenal d'outils que nous devons
déployer pour augmenter le nombre de
médecins les répartir plus équitablement
sur le territoire pour augmenter le
temps médical disponible pour garantir à
chacun une prise en charge effective et
adaptée pour mettre fin aux inégalités
territoriales et financières d'accès aux
soins pour enfin faire vivre aussi le
principe de solidarité envers les plus
fragiles et même si certaines mesures
ont été prise en ce sens ces dernières
années nous avons besoin d'un changement
de logiciel d'ampleur pour faire
réellement de la santé une priorité
nationale nous pouvons à cet égard
regretter l'absence de grands projets de
loi pilotés par le gouvernement pour
s'attaquer à cette désertification
médicale et aux difficultés croissantes
d'accès aux soins à défaut les groupes
parlementaires multiplient des
initiatives forcément partielles comme
c'est le cas sur cette proposition de
loi bien entendu il y a des dispositions
dont nous devons nous réjouir la plupart
sont le fruit du travail transpartisan
qu'un grand nombre d'entre nous a mené
ces derniers mois elles sont la preuve
que nous parvenons à travailler ensemble
et nous entendre sur des sujets majeurs
pour nos
concitoyens aussi nous avons
collectivement inscrit quelques avancées
comme le préavis de 6 mois avant le
départ d'un professionnel de santé
libérale conventionné la dé ation des
capacités d'accueil des étudiants en
priorité par les besoins du territoire
l'expérimentation d'une option santé
dans les lycées des territoires
sous-dotés la limitation des aides et
incitations à l'installation au-delà de
10 ans ou encore la suppression de la
majoration du ticket modérateur pour les
patients perdant leur médecin traitant
ce sont des mesures qui permettront
quelques améliorations à cours ou à long
terme mais à ell seul ell ne résoudront
évidemment pas tous les problèmes
d'autant qu'en par parallèle d'autres
dispositions que nous avions adopté ici
ont été supprimées afin de trouver un
compromis avec les sénateurs celle-ci
était pourtant essentielle je pense
particulièrement à l'obligation de
permanence des soins ou encore à la
possibilité pour les ARS de salariés
directement les médecins il demeure
enfin un sujet qui ne sera pas traité
par cette proposition de loi celui oui
de la régularation de l'installation des
médecin l'urgence de la situation et le
constat des échecs des dispositifs
incitatifs à l'installation en œuvre ces
dernières années devrait normalement
nous contraindre à envisager une telle
solution il s'agit bien d'une régulation
douce dont il serait question ici telle
que proposé par le groupe transpartisan
pour orienter les médecins vers les
territoires les moins dotés un autre
enjeu de long terme réside dans la
formation des médecins et de de l'accès
aux études de santé notre groupe
continue de soutenir la proposition de
notre collègue Jean-Louis bricou sur les
écoles normales des des métiers de la
santé sous la forme des lycées
spécialisés elle assurit le rôle
d'ascenseur social en proposant des
études gratuites un internat
d'excellence et une bourse de vie si le
texte comporte des mesures intéressantes
certaines dispositions font courir le
risque de porter atteinte à l'initiative
territoriale c'est le cas de la
possibilité laisser au ght de se doter
de la personnalité morale nous appelons
à la grande prudence à la matière les
ght ne doivent pas devenir de grands
groupements sans lien avec avec les
territoires et les populations au
contraire notre groupe appelle à plus de
décentralisation plus d'autonomie et de
prise en compte des besoins des
territoires dans nos politiques de santé
nous avons besoin de plus de proximité
et moins de verticalité dans les prises
de décisions sur les territoires et au
sein des hôpitaux aujourd'hui à l'issue
de nos débats qui auraiit sans doute
gagné à être poursuivi nous avons le
sentiment d'un texte pardon un peu
Fourtout les 10 articles initiaux ont
fait place pass à 38 articles qui
apparaissent comme un empilement de
mesures sans réelle vision globale c'est
la conséquence de l'absence de projet de
loi d'ampleur sur la santé depuis
plusieurs décennies je le redis notre
groupe ne s'opposera bien sûr pas à
cette proposition de loi mais appelle à
une réforme beaucoup plus ambitieuse de
notre système de santé je vous remercie
je vous remercie la discussion générale
est close je vais donc mettre au voix la
proposition de loi telle qu'elle est
issue de la Commission mixte paritaire
merci de regagner vos
places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos donc votant 215 exprimé 189
majorité 95 pour 165 contre 24
l'assemblée national à adopté monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez la parole
oui madame la Présidente
simplement quelques mots pour remercier
tous ceux qui depuis plusieurs mois ont
participé aux travaux comme je
l'évoquais de tous les bancs de cette
assemblée on a eu des contributions qui
ont permis effectivement de bâtir un
texte certes qui est partiel ne répond
pas à tous les mots du système de santé
mais néanmoins à travers les 38 articles
ces 38 dispositions concrètes qui
viendront décloisonner territorialiser
et donner plus de d'autonomie d'oxygène
à ceux qui sur le terrain et bien
prennent en charge nos concitoyens c'est
un texte qui était attendu par les
professionnels c'est un texte qui est
soutenu par les associations d'élus
locaux c'est un texte pragmatique
concret et je vous remercie à tous de
votre soutien un grand merci merci aussi
à Madame la Ministre à son cabinet à ses
collaborateurs et à tous ceux qui ont
uvré pour cela merci je vous
remercie